We've been talking a lot about what could
happen between now and the November election
that could propel Donald Trump to reelection.
Now, Trump is down dramatically in a number
of different polls to Joe Biden.
We're going to talk about it a little later.
Right now, Trump is losing among women.
Trump is losing young voters.
Trump's losing older voters, minority voters.
Trump's strong group is middle aged white
men, essentially.
But things can change very quickly.
And there's a piece in The New York Times
by two doctors from the University of Pennsylvania,
including Zeke Emanuel, outlining a scenario
where Donald Trump could force some version
of a Corona virus vaccine into emergency use
in October, an October surprise, so to speak,
and propel himself to reelection.
I would even add an alternative, which is
Donald Trump will take what is already a likely
scenario.
I mean, we a lot of reasonable, sober roadmaps
have said for months now we are sort of expecting
it's like a 50 50, maybe even more likely
shot that there's an emergency use vaccine
for health care workers in the fall.
Trump could simply try to take credit for
it, despite the fact that he would have absolutely
nothing to do with such a vaccine, because
dozens of vaccines have been under development
since before Donald Trump was even taking
Corona virus seriously.
Right now, there are more than 120 candidate
vaccines, ten of which are already in human
trials.
We have phase three trials starting in some
of those vaccines.
And from a mathematical perspective, it's
likely one of these vaccines is going to work
and it will have nothing to do with Donald
Trump.
We have already seen, again, the expectation
from some of the big financial firms which
think what you will about them.
They tend to make analysis that are based,
in fact, many big financial firms and thinking
about the economic recovery are expecting
that by October there will be some vaccine
doses available for health care workers.
And even if all of that fails, Donald Trump
could try to strong arm the FDA to approve
something that's not really ready for approval.
He'd need some pharma company to be complicit.
But the point of the op ed in The New York
Times is this is not completely inconceivable.
And it would, of course, be very dangerous
if it's not actually the right time for a
vaccine to be approved.
But Donald Trump thinks that he could get
an electoral victory by announcing I got the
vaccine before everybody else open up businesses.
I fixed it.
Let's go back to work.
If that happened in mid or late October, it
could generate just enough confusion and craziness
that Trump gets himself reelected, assuming
he suppresses the vote enough in November,
which is another aspect of the 2020 Trump
campaign, limiting the number of people who
end up voting.
So there are a couple of things that would
be important to understand if there were an
emergency use vaccine in the fall.
And I hope there is.
It would in all likelihood only be available
to health care workers and maybe by the end
of the year we would start to see more doses
for some of the most vulnerable Americans.
It would have nothing to do with Donald Trump
whatsoever.
Number two, it is really important to also
understand that a lot of these vaccines even
pre-date this corona virus in the sense that
there are vaccines developed for poultry that
have been around for a while for corona virus
in poultry that are being tweaked.
None of this stuff would have anything to
do with Donald Trump, but it doesn't matter
because it's all optics.
And what can he take credit for?
And what's incredible to see is since the
start of coronavirus, we've seen anti AXA's
spout conspiracies about Bill Gates is the
reason why they wouldn't get a corona virus
vaccine or whatever there is now in light
of this op ed.
There's a crowd of people now who are pro
vaccine but who are worried if.
A vaccine is pushed out in September or October
by Donald Trump's FDA, if it's approved by
Trump's FDA.
People are now legitimately worried.
Would it actually be safe?
Because Donald Trump has started to control
all sorts of regulatory agencies.
They mostly are doing his bidding pro vaccine.
People are worried.
You know, if this is just a Trump stunt in
October, maybe it wouldn't actually be a safe
vaccine, which is an incredible thing to see
and think about.
Last point I want to make from a perspective
of practicality.
Donald Trump has already proven himself completely
incompetent and unfit to lead.
And what's happened up to today justifies
his immediate and speedy removal from the
office of the White House.
Whatever vaccine developments happen between
now and Election Day would have nothing to
do with Trump and wouldn't justify his reelection.
This is a really important point.
Only people who want to get bamboozled by
Trump so they don't feel bad about voting
for him in 2016 and again in 2020 or just
straight up ignorant people are going to fall
for it.
But unfortunately, the 2016 election proves
that there are lots of people who meet that
criteria.
Thus, we have to get out there and make sure
we get every single vote.
While we hope that a vaccine is actually safely
made available as soon as possible, very important
note.
Nobody on the left wants people to die.
Nobody on the left wants the economy to fail
to hurt Trump.
Trump has already justified his immediate
removal.
Again, if he cures cancer and ends a climate
change by November, come and talk to me.
But his actions already justify his immediate
removal.
Tonight, join me for the David Pakman show
chess tournament.
No to sign up for free at David Pakman dot
com slash chest's.
Already over 300 people signed up to play,
hoping for a thousand.
I'll see you at 8:00 p.m. Eastern tonight.
Don't miss it.